I have a plan you've got a plan I have
part of a plan I actually had to get
rescued one time by the girl I was
dating Oh No yeah my brother and I both
were gonna be a stuntman team and we
would throw each other down the stairs
to practice I'd walk around and be like
hi I'm from my Niki here you go for oil
changes $20 pretty great right cash
check or credit card today and we'll
take that but no okay you too he's an
American actor and one of my personal
favorites
he achieved leading men status after
starring in the lego movie and guardians
of the galaxy in 2015 he was named by
Time magazine one of the top 100 most
influential people in the world all
right so I'm just gonna meditate for 20
minutes and then we'll get this going
he's Chris Pratt and here's our take on
his top ten rules for success rule
number two is our personal favorite and
we would love to know what really hit a
homerun for you and make sure to stick
her until the end to hear my special
message to Chris Pratt
[Music]
I have a plan you've got a plan I have
part of a plan what percentage of a plan
I don't know
12% 12% it's real
totally fake that is the most real
authentic hysterical laugh of my entire
life because that is not a plan I am GRU
so what it's better than 11% what the
hell does that have to do with anything
thank you groots the only one of you who
has a clue ah you come to Hollywood and
you're chasing this dream you want to be
an actor you know like there's not a ton
of milestones that are crystal clear
that you know what they look like
because for the most part the things
that are gonna help you get to your goal
are are movies that haven't been written
yet they're jobs that haven't existed
yet you're kind of giving yourself over
to this this thing saying like please I
don't want to be a waiter anymore I want
to be an actor you know yeah and that's
that and so there's very few things that
are crystal clear like images of what
you would want and but one of them is to
work with an icon to work with somebody
like a Steven Spielberg it's so like
when you so that to me was one of you
know my goals you wouldn't even want to
say it out loud because it'd be so
ridiculous as I hear what do you want to
do kid well I want to work with Steven
Spielberg maybe like I don't know you
know some jobs you learn by going to
college and they give you an education
then you bring that to your work and
some jobs you learn by just being on the
job and from cursed part three on all
the way up to Jurassic world my
knowledge of how to be on a set how to
act and how
handle myself on set and approach work
is continuing to grow I've learned a lot
on every job it would be smart went on a
job to be a sponge pick somebody and
learn from I'm getting to the point now
where I have more experience than a lot
of the people that are on the set and
I'm actually at a point where I can
teach other people so that's pretty cool
dude
another thing is you're riding horses
yeah I'm writing these horses is this a
skill you had previous to this film oh
gosh no I would I have been I'm bad bad
I guess that's how I would describe my
horse riding skill with the horses agree
do you think they can sense you're most
definitely okay yep those horses they
can sense it and they see me and I'm a
big guy they're like alright buddy you
don't get on me and not know how to ride
you're too heavy to carry around if you
don't know how to ride and I get on
there I'm like howdy cowboy but you know
you've sewn your whole career you've
never had to ride a horse right never
for any kind of movies no I I was
embarrassed on horses a few times in my
life growing up so I had a contentious
relationship with okay the equine and
was it just that you did lacked a
fundamental understanding of how horse I
treated him like jet skis okay guys I
was like I know I'm just gonna jump on
you and hit the gas and you go right
there like I'm a living being I'm gonna
crush you now okay got ya I just didn't
I didn't I didn't fully put together
that it was a living animal yeah
breathing BG why would you yeah but I
would just jump and say and also my
confidence would quickly outgrow my
skill like in almost everything in my
life okay you only need to do something
for a second to think I think I got this
right yeah oh so this so you you hit it
with this and it walks gonna hit it real
hard and make it sprint okay yeah and
then yeah I actually had to get rescued
one time by the girl I was dating Oh No
yeah that was you on you both you run we
were on horses we were on this beach it
was supposed to be romantic yeah and
then the horse just took off running and
I my feet came out of the stirrups and
my feet were up in the air and my I was
holding the very end of the reins
and my head was bouncing off of the back
of the horse's ass
I was seconds from death this thing is
going about 40 miles an hour down a
rocky beach I was like this is it I'm
gonna die yeah and I hear and then the
girl just like just totally rides up and
saves the day she did I grabbed my reins
and calm the horse yeah and I was just
like that was it and that point and that
moment we broke up in my head yeah
[Music]
you're a stuntman at heart
yeah I always that was my number that's
what I wanted to be when I grew up when
I was a kid I want to be a stuntman and
my brother and I both were gonna be a
stuntman team and we would throw each
other down the stairs to practice not
never get injured you know we were just
like fall out of trees and hit each
other at the car or fall off a bike or
do like cool stunts we always end so
like that the fact that I get to do some
stunts I I shouldn't say that I do all
my stunts I have Joe baccaro as an
excellent stuntman and we have a great
stunt crew that works really hard on our
show but when we when they write
something physical and like a physical
comedy bit I'll usually try one or two
on my own to do and that's really fun I
think is so cool about the guardians of
the galaxy is it opens up the universe
and so like instead of like taking these
new things and bringing them right back
to the stories we already know I think
it's like open it up like see what other
corners of the galaxy we can discover
bring in characters like that weren't
you know bring in characters that were
from some of the guardians of the galaxy
like Explorer yon to explore the aunt
and the origins more of these characters
and if it is Thanos explore the Infinity
Gauntlet like how many of these stones
are you gonna get and who does that open
up like in state versus expands you know
then looking out on it we want to take
these characters and bring them into the
Avengers and we want to like have them
be all in the same movie together it's
like no that make 100 movies I lived in
Maui yeah yeah yeah I lived in a van in
Maui for about a year when I was 19 yeah
yep and so that man right there
Wow would that be you in the van that's
me and that's that's literally the
script that got me out of Maui that
script is for cursed part three the
movie that I got paid $700 to do that
$700 I know I was like that's $700 last
is me one year I bet if they didn't know
you lived in a van you would have got
more money but so then you went back to
shoot this movie Jurassic world how cool
is that to go back and shoot a giant big
blockbuster when you lived in a van it's
it's so so surreal and you know we one
of those weird full-circle things that
happens in life like when I was there I
mean I was having the time of my life I
you know at 19 years old just like
living in a car with my friend and so
there was another guy yeah well yeah so
it wasn't lonely it was pretty awesome
so attracted a storm character star-lord
you know for me when I got really
excited about was that this is an
Earthling this is a kid who was 9 years
old just like me in 1988 I was 9 years
old
and so is he so you got to think this is
a kid who saw Star Wars this is a kid
who saw Indiana Jones and saw Back to
the Future and Footloose and all the
movies that I loved when I was a kid so
if he gets
if it were me and I was him and you know
something tragic happened and then
immediately after I was transported to
space and essentially given a spaceship
and a an opportunity to become whoever
the hell I wanted to be and it was based
on this ideology that's built on an 80's
pop icon's I would be exactly who Peter
quill is in space and I would try to
create star-lord and I would want
everyone to call me star-lord
and no one would and it would be like a
little hints of all these wonderful
heroes from the movies that I watched as
a kid
so that got me really excited I'm
excited that I could kind of just play I
could kind of be just really approaching
it from an acting standpoint try to
ground this thing in some reality I mean
we're out in space it's so fantastical
and and in such a fantasy but you know
well how would it really be I mean you
have to sort of approach these things as
in trying to thread your own reality
into it and so that what's what got me
so excited was like this guy is me it
was it's me man that's what got me thank
God cause if I have to act it's it's
gonna plummet below it hey city gotta
drop it now hey cumin no problem no
problem at all how do you know about
this I don't even know what that is I'm
just a junker man I was just just check
that out you don't look like a junker
you're waiting ravage of God just that
outfit man Ninja Turtle you better stop
poking me what is your name my name is
Peter quill okay dude chill out why
woman may have bushes for you hey you
know what there's another name you might
know me by star-lord who star-lord man
legendary outlaw guys no I don't forgive
this
when I was 18 I or 17 I've graduated
high school and I moved out and became a
door-to-door salesman selling Kirby
vacuum cleaners you know selling much
lower priced items coupons for
businesses in the service industry for
oil changes for $20 three or four trips
to a day selling at the $95 packet yeah
it was just no just one coupon Oh
I'd walk around be like hi I'm from
Meineke here you go for oil changes $20
pretty great right cash check or credit
card today and we'll take that but no
okay a couple doors slammed in your face
oh god yeah
well I did the job for about a year and
a half Jesus got really good at it was
salesman of the year for the company he
had and got a free trip to Jamaica what
yeah I was I became a manager within six
weeks I had a crew I was the perfect
mixture of enthusiasm and sigh and
naivete answer an ad that says do you
like rock and roll music do you want to
make money I was like holy Sh so what's
this rock music okay you're selling
coupon sweet no no you know they don't
sell coupons we ran it we ran
advertising oh okay
so anyways I opened my own business in
Colorado when I was 19 and just lost my
ass point being high turnover rate yeah
we went from door to door year and a
half year and a half trip to Jamaica
trip to Jamaica how do we get to
Colorado that's the whole point is if
you is is if you do well one day you can
have your own office
oh and that we'd like you to run the
object in Colorado yes which I did but
miserable failed miserably um they put a
lien on my minivan pretty bad but
backing up to dance or how I got into
Sam comedy there was a really high
turnover rate in Seattle which is like
one or two new guys a week who would end
up quitting by the end of the week a lot
of the money that you make is just from
them like selling three or four and then
leaving this job anybody's ever done
great prep for being an actor I in terms
of lying in terms of law
walking into a room feeling comfortable
and having thick skin there's no better
Wow thanks again for sure oh my god to
face all that rejects ya people now are
like god I just can't handle the
rejection as an actor I'm like you do
they invite you there yeah you're not
like sneaking in some side door to try
to sell you something first set you know
anyway so I can you can tell me as fat
as I want or you know are as you want
you can tell me anything you want and
it's not gonna hurt my feelings I'm not
really thick skinned from being a
door-to-door salesman we just talked
about the workout regimen I'm very
curious to know what you were doing what
you were eating really yes it was like
turkey patties or chicken or what yeah
that's it I only ate Turkey no I just
eat turkey every day with gravy you know
um yeah it was like it was a really good
it'd be it's hard to actually what I
should do is I should write the whole
thing down and give it to people because
it takes me it took a long it took a
long time it took there wasn't any trick
to it or any secret to it it's just a
matter of getting after it that's the
problem is people want to know what the
secret is the secret is you can't do it
in a month thank you I like that it
takes eight months and or a year or a
lifetime to of consistency working out
every single day and eating properly and
truly feeding yourself not starving
yourself but giving yourself proper
nutrition to heal you have to burn off
all the crap you've put in your body and
then you have to replace it with really
good food and fuel and it takes a long
time but really eight months is not that
long I mean what were you doing in May
right yeah that was yesterday right and
when you're looking back eight months
goes by really quickly when you're
looking forward it seems like a lot it's
crazy so long cross but even eight hours
seems can be right but just takes a
little bit of consistency and time is
gonna go by just as fast whether you're
doing it or not so who do you want to be
eight months from now you want to redo
that you want to be in good shape and
get on it today and this is uh us let's
talk about this this whole your your
your physicality there is there anything
to say
and everybody's been talking about that
but here's the thing
do you enjoy this attention are you sick
of it yet yeah it's a it's so hard you
you actually have something in common
with Channing oh no huh just one thing
um oh yes well recently this is true
it's it is true it's true but it's sort
of it's not really true it's true
I like this I when I was a kid I was in
a small town I was a stripper for a
little while for a little while
[Applause]
[Music]
they was it was very low rent I was like
that was like the very very low rent
magic would you make Oh 40 bucks a pop
did it three times
that's why nowadays everybody want to
talk they got something to say but
nothing comes out when they move the
lips just a budget of a bridge Zac they
forgot about Dre so what do you say to
somebody you hate well anyone trying to
make you buy one of these off things but
you wait we'll just study your tape of
NWA one day I was walking out with the
bar for novel what a kind of guy giving
an Aquanaut stranding them off with the
pocket not you know good food my head
weighs upwards of 85 pounds it's a
16-pound baby my mom carried me to full
term plus eight months I was born at 17
months with a full head of hair a full
head of teeth yes sir show me your GQ
pose no your cover look like oh it was
like this I was doing this thing I
called staring into middle space you
guys get that look yeah it's like right
here right here
can't see it yeah no big deal
People's Sexiest Man Alive 2015 oh
that's uh don't be modest don't be don't
be modest I deserve it dadgummit if
anyone deserves it
it is I do you know yes it is you you I
think we're gonna go man
no I think it's it now is time it's
finally time that they crown a woman as
sexiest man favorite animal
mmm that's a tough one it changes day to
day I would say
Tiger okay favorite vegetable mmm
tiger well you're not actually inside
the body of a raccoon not this time
nor are you inside a tree not
necessarily I have been inside of both
you have what is your beauty regimen
when you are voice acting oh it's the
same as my regular regimen there's a
high sodium diet a lot of salt and soy
sauce on everything also a lot of salt
and soy sauce on my face in the morning
I think it's important to have my eyes
be as close together as possible because
deep down inside everyone wants the
Cyclops vision so if I can fatten the
rest of my face it brings the eyes
closer together for that for that thing
that everyone is just naturally drawn to
so I fatten the face up with a lot of
beer and and empty carbs after midnight
hmm as much as I can out like the
trainer was like if you're gonna do beer
and EPPICard limited to 12 beers and
make sure you do it after midnight
you're outlaw name in the film is
star-lord okay so in real life if you
had to pick a name to represent you as
an outlaw in outer space what would you
what would you pick the boner doctor
boner for hire I also you know I can
lend my medical expertise to your boner
it's now chef doctor is and people I did
bachelorette parties in my hometown
yeah my grandma had me something like
that no I couldn't afford a cop outfit
on my budget the old no I would just
wear I wasn't good I would just like
slowly awkwardly dance and then take go
down to my shorts and they'll be like no
it wasn't ever crazy here you go so it's
not like didn't it was not sex I got it
oh yeah
I also got some dudes briefcase believed
in you buddy but you should put that
back how did you get this [ __ ]
hilarious that's not some than that
props can fix sorry
harder to me try to talk a dog's blood
drugs right next to vici monkeys truck
in a two-car garage
walking out with two broken legs trying
to walk it off you too [ __ ] call the
cops I'm gonna kill you when the loudest
barking dogs on the donkey mouth you
traced it next to a burned-out house
with a can put together the hand for the
matches it still weren't found now right
he's thinking it's a chronic to start
today tomorrow's a new and I stay local
enough to choke you to death with the
tossed into you get to get ticket Slim
Shady
twin babies and Mercedes being with the
windows up to the temples up to the
mid-80s I coming man ladies side doc but
I being crazy it's okay
sort of oh there's this show in London
called Joey it's kind of like the Jersey
Shore of England I think and so I can do
an impression of some of those people
well you yeah it's like was I gonna say
my my cold night tea to me when he was
in Ibiza because like seriously like
he's slightly cooler
all night whatever I went with you
whatever I'm not home stay home say why
may your mother fish breath hey here we
go okay I'm really excited we're gonna
be sending a special message to Chris
Pratt here it is Chris man I love
following you on snapchat you're really
inspirational just the fact that you're
so down to earth your snaps are weird
and they're funny I love a lot of your
movies and TV shows that you've done
I've watched whether it's Parker
recreations whether it's guardians of
the galaxy I can't wait for guardians of
the galaxy to come out and I think the
reason that I follow you is because
you're super hard worker but at the same
time as much famous you have you're just
as relatable as anyone else and that's
something that I really find endearing
and I try to pass on in my classes as an
instructor here for dance side note if
you ever want to learn salsa you're in
Toronto you're welcome to drop by drop
by our school Toronto dance also I would
love to give you a private lesson with
you and your wife hey Chris it would
make my year if you could send me just a
quick hey Alex on snapchat now you you
just have to make sure to say it right
it's Alex with the K s not an X you
pronounce it the same way but it's just
just make sure to remember it to KS but
the reason I would make my year is
because I think of you really as a real
humble guy and a guy who's hard-working
and when I'm teaching class no matter
how good I get at whatever I do I always
try to be relatable to people and just
getting that message from you is gonna
motivate me to continues to stay
connected to my followers the students
and the people who follow me on snapchat
to make it an awesome experience for
them like I've been watching you and
you've made for me so I would really
love to do that you're gonna see a snap
code somewhere around me at some point I
hope to hear a good shout out from you
have an awesome day and continue to
believe so thank you guys so much for
watching I made this video because any
Margaret and Alex asked me to so there's
a famous entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next please leave it down the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know what did Chris
say that really inspired you or made you
think what was your favorite rule please
leave it in the comments below and I'm
gonna join in the discussion and if
anybody has any
a connection to Chris I know I know I
know it would really be special and
meaningful to Alex if you could forward
it on to him so he can see it that's it
for me today thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon